we are going to begin with the news and
the news this morning is the weather a
major Coast-to-Coast winter storm and
another one on the way the first system
arriving in the East this morning
carrying dangerous conditions you see
them on your screen now and the second
is starting up in California take a look
at these pictures that is the entrance
to a major freeway in the Sierra Nevadas
and those are people skiing across it
back here in the East Earl Barnett is
watching the snowfall for us in Bristol
Connecticut Errol good morning
that's right we're trying to capture
some of that snowfall for you now Good
morning Tony I can confirm that winter
weather has finally arrived here to the
Northeast everything you see around me
here in Bristol Connecticut this is
fresh snowfall from overnight it's
roughly 25 degrees right now but there
are winter weather alerts spanning from
Minnesota to Maine and in New York City
even the city experienced its first real
winter weather of the season
while there hasn't been much snow for
the Northeast the region is now getting
hit by the biggest storm of the season
on the final day of the last full month
of winter
meanwhile near the Great Lakes where
residents typically expect snow the
region is covered in ice from freezing
rain it was a big snowstorm last week
and it's raining today I never know what
to wear outside anymore it's horrible
it's part of the same system that began
with rare blizzards in Southern
California
before unleashing 110 mile per hour
winds in the Southern Plains the whole
house is caved in at that time I'm
trying to get my sister to safety
University of Oklahoma football player
Corey robison's home was destroyed by a
tornado he and his sister hid in a
bathtub when it roared through his
teammates showing up the next day to
help clean up it means the world to me
you know not everybody has you know the
much health the much help as we do in
the world but just as these storms begin
to exit the East another Coast to Coast
system is brewing in the west
Steve large from our CBS Sacramento
station is in stormwirey California
I'm standing in the middle of one of the
major corridors through the Sierra this
is Highway 50 closed because of
treacherous conditions they're measuring
snowfall and feet here visibility is
near zero at times in blizzard-like
conditions are expected through tomorrow
businesses are closed government
buildings are closed and schools are
closed and all the roadways leading into
Yosemite are close to the public through
tomorrow we're just making sure we have
enough Propane and Gas for our generator
and water in case our pipes freeze
residents at lower elevations are facing
threats of dangerous mudslides on soaked
hillsides I'm very bored it's not just
Meats everybody's worried around here
now that storm that's just getting going
in California right now is expected to
hit the southern Rockies by Thursday uh
carrying with its snow to the central
plains and yes folks here on the East
Coast we could see more snowy weather by
the end of the week Nate
Errol thank you